- I get my best performance
when there's like a meaningful object,
like in the set
or like in the scene.
- Did you use that for the film?
- No, 'cause we were alone.
- All alone.
We were alone in a recording booth.
(light music)
- I took from my parents a little bit
'cause they're theater kids.
They met in theater
and then they created a theater kid
that got to play a theater kid.
So Margot is really big and expressive
and loud and every moment is the moment.
It's curtain call at all times.
She is on stage at all times.
She's, you know, producing,
directing her friends at all times.
She's just a nut.
- Oh, life is not a dress rehearsal.
It's time for you to go big
and go
to prom.
- So I spent a lot of my summertime
at my parents' cottage
and there's a big rock
by the lake and I would spend like
a lot of time lounging on the rock,
willing myself to become a mermaid.
Just being like, "Come on, grow a tail."
- I'm a mother flipping mermaid.
- So I did that for a while,
so I feel like I would,
I feel like I had to
draw something from that.
- Ruby gets like overwhelmed very quickly.
She spirals very easily.
That's something as a
performer, fun to play.
It's so tough because the physicality
when you're in a recording booth
you don't have a lot of freedom there
because you don't wanna move too much
because you don't wanna
like have the fabric pick up
on any of the mics and you don't wanna,
you know, move away from the mics,
but to me, I found that
if I was able to do
like even just like wrap
my limbs like together
or hold myself a little,
it helped my performance.
I knew that they were
gonna try and animate her
kind of in that capacity.
Oh, I hope my performance
was better because of it.
- Ruby Gillman, teenage kraken.
(laughs)